really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta while the water
comes to the boil start the sauce by
slicing mushrooms first off fingers one
in front two behind up and down then add
olive oil to a hot frying pan I want
that nice color on the mushrooms off the
heat
listen ten seconds and when you toss
something really important you get all
the ingredients get into the pan push
down and pull back that noise s that's
all the water coming out the mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
then prepare your leeks just take your
knife and go down through the center
turn it over and again into quarters see
all that opening up and then just rinse
the top of that you get rid of any
potential dirt sand it just breaks up
into nice little quarters have all that
leek those mushrooms beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leak as it cooks down
all the waters gone in to set out a new
night intense flavor Garland's got nice
and crispy now we'll add a touch of
chicken stock in there the Sonia sheets
drop the sheets in to the water lasagna
sheets are an unusual choice for a dish
like this but they work brilliantly
although any type of pasta you've got in
the cupboard will do and just twist that
pan that stops any pasta actually
sticking to the bottom of pan chicken
start with reduce down by half and it's
almost good lays the bottom of the pan
basically washed all that wonderful
flavor off turn the gas down and add a
couple of tablespoons of cream this just
enriches the dish bring it back up the
ball and let it simmer for 3 to 4
minutes now the secret of the pasta it's
just taking it out a little early so you
got that a nice texture hold up the
sheet and just nip it you can feel your
fingers in the center it's ready turn
the sauce down and lay these beautiful
sheets on the Sonya into that sauce just
got to turn the gas off now and let the
pasta sit in there and absorb that
amazing sauce finish with chopped fresh
tarragon it's a delicious herb and gos
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit almost sort of infuse
to serve I'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh ciabatta bread to nice
slices drizzle that in olive oil
a bit of garlic just rub the bread the
crust as well crust is what really takes
that garlic now pan for the bread in
touch of olive oil as it starts to smoke
bread in but look at the pastor now it's
in stained by that amazing sauce to
serve on a nice spoon of my mushrooms
leeks and cream then I'll take my pasta
just twist it and let it sit on top that
tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on and that's the beauty about
something so simple they can be done in
20 minutes with everyday ingredients a
stunning pastor dish having easy and
versatile dishes like this to your
repertoire is what cooking at home is
all about so can always make great
tasting food at the drop of a hat a fry
off the chilies ginger the garlic first
sesame seed or teaspoon only in fried
corn-on-the-cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderful each our
flavor